being a mom is one of the most rewarding
it's not one of the most it's the most
but it's also exhausting one of the most
exhausting jobs
that you'll ever have i have two
daughters and i do not even know how the
woman we're about to speak about does
what she does
so one of our missions on this show is
to make sure that moms feel connected
and supported and heard and maybe even
giving them a break when they need it
most
and our guests today are the parents of
not one
not two not three not four
but five kids all under three years old
so when this husband reached out to
nominate his wife for a mom's time out
i knew we'd love to help
my name is chris sturm my wife katie and
i have five kids
we have a three-year-old toddler named
ryan and we recently
as of july have a set of quadruplets we
have austin
daniel hudson and jacob drew i want to
nominate my wife katie for a mom's time
out
katie is a very kind very loving woman
she loves our kids
very much she's so sweet and so good to
them and they love her every time they
see her
austin especially because he's the
little smiley one they love their mama
and they're very happy that she's around
with them as
am i i'm very happy she's here with them
and with us she's just a great
mother and a very kind very loving very
funny
partner in this crazy journey that we're
on drew
my wife katie absolutely deserves a
mom's time out
because five days a week she is at home
with a toddler and
four infants with some help from her
family and my family
every week she spends a lot of time
with her children and she doesn't get a
whole lot of time for
herself which she absolutely deserves
after the year that we've had
she 100 deserves a mom's time out
[Applause]
well please welcome a very kind husband
chris hi chris hi drew how are you
i mean i loved when i first saw your
video
uh before this that just all women
i think would love you know to hear
their
partner saying
you know i see the work that this mom is
doing this
wife this woman and it really just
affected me because sometimes
just that recognition is like
bigger than any present you could get i
mean
how do you manage all of this the best
way i can describe any of this to y'all
is it's controlled chaos so usually
between the hours of like 7
a.m and 9 p.m somebody's making noise
somebody's being fussy
somebody's holding somebody you know i
get home from work about 5
5 30 in the afternoon um and we're
feeding babies and usually at about six
or seven and i've got two of them with
me in a rocking chair
so it's it's a lot to adjust to
you know having one baby was enough and
then we had four more to add on to it
so it's it's very interesting to say the
least
how old are the quads now uh they
are four months uh as of the third
and is it still feeding now how often
let's see everyone and that also is
very you know that last bottle before
bed
is like everything i mean i remember
when my babies
i would get that last bottle the seven
ounces and i would get
one of them up for the burp and they
would spit the whole thing out and i
would just cry i would just be like
no that was the anchor for the night
yep yeah yep i know i feel i know that
feeling 100
we had one one time where three out of
the four babies puked the entire thing
back out and my wife and i literally
just looked at each other and we're like
what are we doing i i can only imagine
um katie also had a difficult pregnancy
um
was this planned did this
magically happen how did the universe
and god
and the creation and all of it how did
your lives become this
tell us please the journey so uh
we were originally trying for one we
already have one we're trying for one
more we thought have a boy have a girl
be done with it
a-okay well we ended up having four and
we found out we had four of them at the
very first ultrasound and
shortly after we found out we found out
we were gonna have quads at the end of
january and shortly thereafter about two
three weeks later
she had a seizure at work and it was
discovered she had a brain tumor
um and we actually ended up having the
brain tumor removed
at the onset of all of the lockdowns
from the pandemic
not only was i afraid for what was
happening in the operating room
i was afraid for what was happening
outside of the hospital in the world
and so we were lucky we had a really
awesome neurosurgeon i love her
um she got the tumor katie came home and
recovered
and then come to about july 3rd
we had four little four little bundles
of joy
i think you guys might be the only one
who can pretty much one-up
everybody for the 2020. um well
when we come back we're gonna hear from
katie
um your other counter hero and
uh we're gonna hear from her what it's
like being the mom of quads and
i just can't wait to get back to you
guys we're back with chris
and katie sturm who recently gave birth
to
quadruplets and are adjusting to
parenthood of multiples hi katie how
are you how are you drew
um not to be shallow but i love your lip
color
thank you girls it's the little things
that you know
perk us up
it's not it's not it's a girl thing
completely chris
katie i've had the you know
pleasure and privilege of speaking and
laughing with and talking with chris
for a little while now what is your
experience
with all of this you superhero mom
you know i found out that i was having
quads and
that kind of i was just in shock and
you know then we decided to get the
brain surgery
after i had an i had two seizures
actually so
after the second one we decided that you
know sooner would be better to get the
surgery
um and so we did and
the babies were okay after and i was
relieved about that
you know it was really just about the
kids and
i had to pull through for them you know
i know this has been such a huge
year for everyone on this planet but i
really do think that you guys deserve
another level of a medal and um
you know you have a lot of babies and
require a lot of diapers
um which you know is a huge undertaking
so
our friends at uh diaper bamboo diapers
and nikki's natural wipes want to give
you
a year's worth of diapers and wipes for
each of your babies
[Applause]
that's awesome thank you um and actually
um katie your strength and resiliency
has just been
so inspiring and your husband chris
uh did a video that had you know
the girl and me swooning as far as
you know he just talked about what an
amazing mom you are
and how deserving of everything good
um that you have coming to you
and that you totally deserve a mom's
time out so we're gonna send you and
chris
to austin texas for some much needed
alone time
i can't think of anyone who deserves it
more so
we have a five night luxury getaway with
a
personal chef who will just
take care of you at the casa cartel
austin's beautiful urban retreat it's
gorgeous
and everything is going to be taken care
of
spas and food and just ultimate
like recharging of your batteries have
too much wine one night
sleep in be healthy clean
out recharge the batteries and just
you're so
deserving it almost feels not like
enough so i'm gonna throw in five
thousand dollars just go on a shopping
free
and just oh my goodness in washington
proper which is one of my favorite
cities in the world and please remember
how much both of you deserve this and
everybody has to
step away for a second and sort of
honestly i think it is
as simple as recharging the batteries so
you can
you know just you hit it on the head you
have to do it
you have to do it so much
okay perfect so i have a question for
you drew yeah
would you like to meet the kiddos are
you kidding
i would love to meet the kiddos so drew
this is hudson he's the little guy
he's little happy hudson the oh this is
the big guy
so this is jacob he's the big dude oh hi
jacob oh
oh wait here's another one here's daniel
he is hold on he's the tall skinny man
oh hi and then this
let's go heads up ryan heads up this is
austin
well i hope you can see him how fitting
i'm
austin and ryan how do you feel about
being a big brother
do you like it i don't see you you like
your brewers ryan
yes i went out here okay
i i would beautiful boys
welcome to the world boys
i i am just in awe i mean
you guys are amazing parents thank you
well chris and katie thank you so much
and we'll be checking in
i hope that's okay
[Music]
you